i've interviewed over 50 serial killers
but whitaker norris were the first that
ever gave me nightmares
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god hi
with me george lopez
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george lopez oh my god omg omg hi
ever pull it in the driveway after a
trip to the grocery store
only to release you forgot that one key
ingredient for dinner now you have
options get the groceries you need or a
backup meal for your favorite local
restaurant delivered to with doordash
for limited time
for our listeners 25 off and zero
delivery fee on the first order of 15
or more
when you download the door dash app and
enter the code omg hi so download the
doordash app and enter the code
omghi
for this special deal
well first of all hello
thank you for being on the podcast this
is
right in my
wheelhouse i've always wanted to be a
criminal but never having the guts to be
one
i am such a fan by the way
thank you very much i i mean you know
you know mr gill right gil carrillo yes
happy birthday by the way thank you
thank you very much
she did her homework i didn't know you
know
when you have uh
this many years the averages
average male lives to be i think it's 80
years old
so i told my spouse this morning i said
just look at it this way i've only gone
about eight more years
and we're good to go you know the
to be
considered old age as a latino 24
yeah to
deteriorate that for sure you get
shorter
um
so how are you spending your i mean i
can imagine that
undertaking that we want to introduce
our guests
of course
joining us on the podcast today
yeah
criminologist laura brand uh wrote a lot
about the and a lot of investigative
work into the toolbox killer killers
killers killers plural
um you know
how was a how was one of the would you
con
i mean people use monsters a lot but i i
don't know monsters kind of from the
movies right this guy would not be
considered a monster i would think him
and his partner right they're
they've got to be really like a good
mostly i mean they're yeah monsters i
mean
when i first read the like i read a book
in college about them i thought oh my
god they're demonic i mean for what they
were doing um
yeah i would say these are these are the
two of the worst of the worst i mean
especially you know hitting la
gil i know you have a lot of them
i i'd consider them a monster they were
torturing
they were doing things that normal
people just don't do not even serial
killers do
a torture yeah richard wasn't a torture
did they torture animals uh i don't know
about animals i don't know what they
were doing to people but as
kids i think the dahmer i mean jeffrey
dahmer they say as a as a teenager as a
young kid would walk around with like a
german shepherd head on a stick or put
it on somebody's fence with back then
you would think that would be demonic
but it's a start i think right
i think you can definitely start yeah
definitely they tortured the animals you
know whittaker was taking out bunny's
teeth with pliers and that kind of stuff
um so yeah that is something you do see
with these serial killers you know the
torture of the animals then they were
telling me he was selling the feed his
lucky rabbit's foot
unlucky i could see a mexican dentist
doing that pulling
you get a start
you know they don't even have an office
they got like a van you know people used
to go get their teeth taken out of the
van
they did they had a tent a dentist that
had a a van that you would go in there
and sit in the back and the dude would
work on your teeth in the van
like an astro band
that's awful you know it's funny because
whittaker was actually a uh dental
hygienist right before he started all
this and um but i could totally see why
he wanted to go into that type of work
with the
dental you know like to see people in
pain and that kind of stuff and you're
going to see that with sadist you know
they like to go into hospital work
um unfortunately police work sometimes
and you know they love to see people in
pain they love to have that control over
people
there has been a lot of those where a
nurse
would like euthanize people right if
they were suffering but they were not
going to die yet
a nurse would do that and then they've
had a couple of them within the last 20
years that have been
serial killers that were
working in nursing homes and old folks
homes
yeah
yeah i think that
and are they made by
does anybody come from a good background
and become one of those a serial killer
or a murderer or sadist
from like i've
had a couple from good backgrounds
actually which were really surprising
you know usually i'm finding i find a
lot of neglect neglect is like the
biggest one i find
but um i found a couple with you know
good childhoods that have turned into
you know serial killers you know so this
is kind of back to that nature verse
nurture of what's playing a factor into
it you know i think people are born a
psychopath by social personality and
they're also you know nurture can
actually you know boost them
into this kind of life of crime and
serial killing so it's kind of i always
describe as like a perfect storm you
know when you're looking at the storm
plaza coming in
you know all these phones are coming
into play to park to turn them into what
they are what about bundy what kind of
childhood did he have because he wasn't
a bad
really bad guy other than he liked to
kill
uh yeah that way the judge said he'd
have been a great attorney yeah he was a
college student smart intelligent good
looking i but i don't know what kind of
background he had as a child
his
his mom and dad looked like yeah yeah um
yeah
they look like the all-american parents
as his mom and dad his mom
had like a sweater theodore was a
gentleman like that like you're like
this woman is a sleeper this woman can't
be real
theodore was very i don't know where he
makes these things up
like that kind of stuff
yeah well you know his mom he thought
his mom was his older sister for a
couple years and his aunt actually
remembers him putting knives into the
beds when he was three years old so
there's always some type of like little
sign
from the family members typically from a
young age
man that's got to be tough man you're
like three's pretty nice in the bed and
i just think yeah i and you know
did those guys ever say to you like i
didn't want to be this
did they regret anything
oh yeah whittaker said all the time you
know if i had one loving parent if i
just had one loving parent i would have
never become this monster that you know
turn into
you know so parents kind of i don't know
if you guys saw the documentary his
parents you know gave him up and um he
was adopted within the family and the
adopted parents he says were very
neglectful he never went to a birthday
party never had anything pretty much
normal kids have and he felt like a you
know a tenant with a room and board just
living with them the entire his entire
youth pretty much
that's pretty tough huh well it is i i
don't know i don't know that i buy all
that stuff they're looking for an excuse
that that gives them a way out this is
why i am the way i am was because the
way i treat i was treated so he's got an
avenue to place blame
without having to accept blame for what
he did on his own ramirez
said
why do you think i did this why do you
think i was this way he asked me that
and so
he wasn't blaming it on anybody and i
and i just told him hey if i knew the
answer to that i'd be a doctor making a
lot more money than i am as a cop right
here i don't know why you're like that
nor do i really care
you know but yeah you know i get that
that question a lot from serial kill say
will ask me you know why am i this way
it's almost like they're trying to
figure it out too in their own way you
know they're curious about it too what
turned them into this you know person
who wants who likes to kill who's
getting off on killing and loves to play
with the cops which gill you're very
very familiar with um
but that's a question i get a ton from
them
so you know gil said that you know
remember when you went to
your teacher over there and he said what
do you consider like a romantic evening
like you go out and you go to a have
dinner and then you go to a movie and
then you have dessert maybe you
make love then that was their night but
them lighting the fire or waiting around
and watching people suffer or be
tortured was the way that they kind of
got there that is sex to them that that
derives their sexual deviance
yeah i mean
and there's no shortage of i mean
there's some people that have never been
caught
you know there's no shortage of of of
these guys what why do you think that
those guys felt
as comfortable as they as they did with
you and did you
see them like you could remove the part
of the
of the person and then talk to them
because it did you know i'm not trying
to be sympathetic toward those guys but
they really kind of seemed like they
needed like a friend right
somebody yeah that could listen to him
he always wanted that family sense and i
feel like in a sense i kind of gave it
to him you know i'm going in there
pregnant and you know the father is out
of the picture and i'm kind of desperate
so for him it was like you know um
here's a girl who needs my help and
needs me and you know um
i think for him you know he was there
when you know my son romeo was kicking
and stuff so he kind of got like that
um
family sense that i guess he never had
you know with me and romeo and even
after romy was born
you know a year he was dying he died
about a couple months after romeo was
one but you know he was calling on his
birthday calling me during labor i feel
like he had this sense with romeo and it
was weird too because you know romeo was
born uh blonde hair blue eyes like me
uh but same and lauren's bitter and he
said to me he goes i see myself in romeo
and i was like why do you see yourself
in romeo and he goes the single mother
the single mother struggling being born
here so i feel like this weird kind of
um
it's it's hard to explain you know the
circumstances i was placed in and then
i'm working with this serial killer and
he's actually you know
empathetic to where the situation of my
son is in and he's seeing himself with
my son in a way like he sees himself as
my son and seeing him with like you know
the single mother struggling type of
dynamic so
you know there was a lot of factors i
played into against him you know
feeling the way he did and feeling like
he had a sense of family and wanting to
open up
you know and
that i had worked it was three years
before he even finally picked up the
phone to call me i had met with him in
2016 or 15 2015 or 16 i went and met
with him he would not send me a visiting
form i actually had a goal in san
quentin to get another serial killer to
actually get a visit for him to sign off
and i sent him in
and i went and i went to visit him and
that was our first meeting and then we
didn't talk he didn't call but he was
still right a couple letters back but he
was saying in his letters back i don't
want to talk to you but i just kept
insisting persisting persisting and it
was finally after like three or four
years that damn just broke and he
finally called and he finally started
opening up and it was shortly after he
gave me you know the placements of the
bodies were up in san gabriel mountains
and you know with the buried evidences
which is actually right where you guys
are in burbank
you you know that he probably thought
about it every day of those three years
right like obsessed with it and then
finally right i think he would have
there's no upstairs there's no doubt
uh that he did and there's no doubt
that he was at least in the beginning
working her
because
she is like disneyland to him you're
begging me your big and then get into
her and now he gets empathy from her now
he's got a friend
and it works to his advantage as well
wow yeah
it is a quid pro quo kind of like
relationship between the two of you you
both are kind of going in for something
you're both getting something out of it
it's it's very you know silence of the
lambs is
it's [ __ ] totally science
and what about when he's describing
stuff to you you have to be like i gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here
mate right i mean he's locked he's in
san quentin but i mean as somebody's
talking to you
so casually i just saw a documentary so
casually
and very kind of you know
i i can't believe i i take my hat off i
i'm very open i told her
the night that we did meet
uh
she's a very young lady
to get to where she's at to get the
amount of time that she had with him i
mean it takes people a full career
before you get there i mean and and i
was exposed to an awful lot but it took
me years and years and years before i
felt comfortable talking to somebody
like that
uh
okay i appreciate that
it's really phenomenal but she got in
that early and you know as far as uh you
know serial killers are where would they
be on the list they're not as high they
should be because i think the more
they're the most demonic sadistic
uh [ __ ] guy and you know that's why
yeah
well and maybe too laura for the
audience you want to explain a little
bit of who the toolbox killers are what
they did just for some context too
yeah so the urban legend of where the
van i like that murder van the white van
or whatever that actually comes from
whittaker north
they were trolling up and down you know
south bay in los angeles uh picking up
girls teenage girls um hitchhiking some
were actually abducted straight into the
band they pulled them right in the first
victim cindy was walking home from
church
and they threw in the van and they drove
them up to san gabriel mountains
now this is where they tortured and
raped them for even days and until they
finally killed them and they're known
for putting the ice pick into the
victim's ear and you know it didn't kill
them instantly
and they would actually have to take it
out and the other ear they would also
strangle them on top of that this is
after hours of torture and
you know i think one of the reasons
they're not as well known is something
that i've been hit back with with
writing the book now and i'm i've been
talking to an agent
and um some other people you know
production companies in hollywood you
know a big thing especially daytime tv
when i was supposed to go on daytime to
promote the show
this case is so dark a lot of people
don't want to touch it so this is why
kind of reasons it hasn't been as you
know as a ted bundy or jeffrey dahmer is
um networks get scared books get scared
you know of wanting to cover this case
but it is an important thing that we
need to cover i mean it sheds a lot of
light on how we can be hyper vigilant
for teenage girls especially these guys
were going on to the beach and actually
giving you know forms out saying we're
model scouts we're directors we'll get
you into hollywood we'll do this and
these girls are just signing over you
know their addresses and social security
numbers to these predators so it's kind
of like it really is an important um
case that people need to you know hear
about just for their own safety
hyper vigilance but also you know these
girls need to be remembered too and two
of the girls are still up in san gabriel
mountains as well
oh wow
it is a very dark uh case and i i've
actually
heard one of the tapes
that
laura didn't have access to
and nobody has access and when i heard
it
because i was working homicide bureau at
the time and the investigators were
friends of mine
but i listened to it and it is so blood
curling i tried to make it i wanted it
mandatory for every new homicide
investigator to come into the bureau
to sit down and listen to it so they
could hear
that this is not
a place of glory or nothing this is real
this is not a game
you have to be prepared for this stuff
if you're going to work up here
you know um
and also you know people that
glorify that
um you know like i mean i have better
things to do than worry about how many
serial killers are out there or
finding out about them
but
i just think you know there's there's
still even though social media and i
think you you can agree that
people are still as naive
regarding that kind of stuff as they
were before that kind of stuff where
somebody guy could just
walk up to you and because he looks like
the kind of person that you would assume
was friendly
that you would start engaging in
conversation
is that is that kind of true yeah
100 i think especially now in this day
and age where everybody wants to be like
an instagram model or star or tick tock
or whatever you know and whittaker at
the time he was making um
uh crazy money i mean he was making a
hundred thousand dollars this is back in
1979.
um so he was waving money around and
especially i think when young girls are
getting you know approached by an older
man waving money around they're thinking
he's a big shot
and the thing is so can a predator do
that and then we have stuff like you
know shades of gray
where you know this like young handsome
guy comes waving money around and
that you know turn into a love story but
the fact of the matter is it turns into
a criminal minds episode very very
quickly
but i only had money to wave around i
could have had a different lifestyle
i had money to wave around and i turned
it into horror
but uh yeah yeah yeah and how did those
guys how did they meet again the two
toolbox
how did they met in prison up in san
luis obispo they they met and um
so whitaker was working in a wood shop
and uh norris actually made jewelry that
was like what he loved to do was make
jewelry and he taught whitaker how to
make jewelry so it was actually a group
of them it was a group of these guys in
prison and they would talk about their
fantasies that were all the same about
you know kidnapping and torturing and
killing young women so it actually
turned into group of them it wasn't even
just bitter norris so they were actually
sending in pictures of the victims back
into their friend richard shootman
back at um you know san luis obispo so
and they were sending him messages just
by picture saying hey we've gone through
with the plan that we planned you know
in prison and then a lot of them
actually got out and they all moved to
los angeles um county
and that's when uh joe jackson was a
friend of them he was actually prowling
with them to go with out on the rapes
who you see in the show and jackson was
the one who actually went to you know
authorities and said these guys are
actually killing them you know he was
only into it for the reigns not for the
killing so he actually went back
it's pretty scary because it was kind of
like it was like this group of these
sexual deviants all got together you
know in prison and outside of prison as
well
i mean rodney akala did it but he did it
by himself yes he's a good looking dude
young
and you know uh when he was on the
dating game right in your caller
and
he won
and the woman like talked to him and she
was like this dude is creeping me out
and didn't and didn't go on the date
with him
yep
fun fact about um him as well he was
actually hunting at knott's berry farm
which is also a hunting ground that
bittaker and horsey use the same month
they were there in june of 1979.
so you got to think three serial killers
are both using the same hunting ground
back in 1979 i mean these serial killers
back then were like on top of each other
in los angeles and why did they choose
uh knott's berry farm
well knott's berry farm you know young
girls you know teenage girls that's
where they go to hang out they're away
from their parents they're you know they
tell their parents we're gonna go hang
out at this you know amusement park many
teens all teenagers you know they just
go to music parks hang out same with the
beach yeah it's cheaper than disneyland
and back then we didn't have magic
mountains so it's either disneyland or
knott's berry farm
that's very
you think that they did alpine village
too because that's cheaper than us very
far
i think
we're always still over there village
yeah yeah yeah and how is the book
coming along
it's good um i just got an agent on and
we're getting ready to you know go to
publishers so it's it's working it's
gonna be a long one i'm already at like
a hundred and almost thirty thousand
words at this point so it's gonna be a
big one
you know it's a huge piece we had five
police departments covering it and then
we had los angeles sheriff's department
which gill was very close to one of the
lead investigators over there dennis
um
so we have you know it's a massive case
and then on top of this massive pace and
the back story i have to write about i
have to write about my interviews and
you know the years i spent working with
betika and norris too so it's going to
be a long one
how did you find your way to crime
me uh honestly nancy drew when i was a
little girl
classic um dad would sit there and read
nancy drew to me and i came became
obsessed i wanted to be nancy drew i
wanted to kind of go out there and solve
mysteries and that kind of stuff and
then i it led me to you know true crime
it was a young girl and then i was
reading you know serial killer books fbi
profile books in high school and then i
went to school for forensic psychology
and
it was a professor who told me you know
start doing your own study and start you
know moving these serial killers on your
own and um i did i took it and ran with
it and that's what led me actually to
whitaker norris and san quentin
man that's
i i probably in all
in all likelihood
because of her youth because of her lack
of experience and the way she went about
it
i probably wouldn't have spent a lot of
time with her
before because it would have been in my
eyes somebody who did it for a living
and looking at this is a fantasy this
she really doesn't know what she's doing
now after the fact now knowing her
background knowing what she did
now it was very exciting
it was very surprising for me when i met
with her
sat down and we met at her request she
wanted to meet with me so we went i gave
her the time and
i'm fascinated by her story and how far
she's gone at this young age she's got
a big big career ahead of her
thank you
it's it's a wild story i mean i really
started out from nothing and i've just
built this study and uh broke this
serial killer at such a young age you
know this sadistic serial killer is such
a young age
and you know i've done this documentary
have this book coming out so it's it's
been a whirlwind so i've been like
looking up to people like gil
you know
to help mentor me through this kind of
wild journey of serial killers and how
to deal with them and work with them and
you know kind of uncover what's never
been uncovered like the missing victims
and the buried evidence kind of stuff
yeah because you know the all of their
families deserve you know they just
everybody deserves to have the
just
the finality of
knowing
at least knowing what happened right i
mean yeah it's got to be 20 percent
i'm curious
uh throughout my career i learned how to
divorce myself from personal feelings
from what i had to do what i was seeing
what i was working and divorce myself
and it's never
never bothered me
uh other than
children bothered me i i didn't like
working around kids
uh
has any of this your studies your work
what you've done
your
time with uh whittaker
has it ever given you nightmares have
you ever thought about what uh what
they've done the torture
the murders
wrote a chapter
yeah i just wrote a chapter i had many
nightmares it was
so i've interviewed over 50 serial
killers but whitaker norris were the
first that ever gave me nightmares i
think it's because you know he also gave
me the police discovery so i'm you know
going back and reading you know the
detective notes
the you know the court transcripts and i
just dug so deep into the case i started
having nightmares ironically having the
same nightmares as the district attorney
stephen k and the nightmares were that i
would be running up san gabriel along
those dirt roads the fire roads and i
would hear the screams of the girls and
i'd get to the van
and they would open the door
and the dead body would drop out it
would be one of the girls and they would
hop out and laugh and say you didn't
make it in time laura
and mine were a little more personalized
because i actually had a best friend who
was murdered so
whitaker and norris would jump out and
talking to me like i would talk to them
on the phone and they would say you know
you couldn't save them you couldn't even
save your best friend so that was a
nightmare that i've been having and
a couple others
but yeah this was the first case that
actually gave me i guess what you would
call like um
post-traumatic stress from the case or
just going to deep bookcase is the
nightmare it's definitely started with
whitiker norris
uh yeah i would say and that's i mean
it's so specific to your own you know
mind and memories in combination with
these guys that stuff
yeah
yeah because it's interesting there was
one there was one nightmare where i had
i actually woke up from the nightmare
and i turned over my bed and
it was bitter next to me in the bed
smuggling and i i said i was calm but i
said you're not allowed to be here and
he goes where is my laura and i said my
subconscious and that's when i woke up
but it was like i even knew that he had
invaded my subconscious like even in my
dream state
that probably a natural reaction wake up
next to her and he's smiling at her
yeah
that happens to me nobody ever wakes up
next to me and they're smiling
[Laughter]
they're wide awake everybody that wakes
up next to me is when i wake up they're
already awake like
even chihuahuas like i would have my dog
sleep with me in the middle of the night
they'd do the walk of shame out of there
maybe they could even they couldn't hang
out the whole night
you're not supposed to be here yeah i'm
not supposed to in the end
what do you want to eat tonight maybe
you want a home-cooked favorite meal
but don't feel like going to the store
or you want something exciting and new
but it would be great to stay in tonight
doordash connects you with everything
you want whenever and however you want
it
it's time to get back out there but if
you're not quite ready for a full-blown
adventure
there's still ways to explore the world
from the comfort of your home
with doordash you don't need to travel
far to experience something new get the
doordash look
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
first order of 15 or more when you
download the door dash app that's 25 up
up to a 10 value and zero delivery fees
on your first order when you download
the doordash app don't forget that's omg
hi for 25 off your first order with
doordash subject to change and terms
apply and i even wrote a song the door
dash look available at bullocks
in the in the
in the serial killer like the idea like
was another question but i think netflix
in order to make ted bundy
more appealing left out a lot of the
horrific details of his crimes in order
to make him almost like a star which is
i think is incredibly wrong
if you look at how bad these guys are
that you want to maybe sugar coat them
to make them more appealing so that
people can
become enamored with them and kind of
you know just look at it it's not
studying them they're kind of
entertained by them we shouldn't be
entertained by that
right and i think you know even with the
documentary of the toolbox killer uh we
left out pretty much all of the torture
in in the series i mean it really does
not go into anything that they really
actually did to the girls you know it's
kind of just saying like an overview of
what happened
and do they hate women like that because
are they females women their mom or
a teacher or where is that hate like
that's where does that come from
[ __ ] rejection rejection
yeah they were rejected by women richard
was rejected when he was a kid so
he was a kid but rejection now it's time
to get back get even
um yeah yeah yeah and it's always uh
well i think you know in in as far as
relationships in in somebody's life
the mother is the you know yeah you know
it's your mom it's like the person that
you love unconditionally
if if she's not there or i mean listen
matt i mean my mom was out there but i
never thought my mom was my sister so i
would think of you
she acted like she was my sister very
mature but i think when you lie to a kid
and tell them that
that's their older sister and it's their
mom is
i mean that's that messes you up yeah
typically
it definitely does you know
um
the green river killer i think his mom
would
uh like wear a robe and it was
open yeah she would like dress like 90s
and stuff in front of him and very
sexualized in front of him
there's a uh
a writer
they did the movie i don't remember it
was
uh
l.a confidential
he's a famous uh
writer yeah who is that guy see if i can
grab him
james elroy james elroy
he had
he listened to his books on tape he did
one of his books
and although he was never a killer and
this was his fantasy
he did he came to our bureau
years after his mother had been murdered
and
she was
loose
and yet he talks in his book about how
sometimes he had fantasies about his own
mother
you know she used to bring drunks down
there and several men down the house and
he could still smell her and
it was uh in his books every one of his
all of his material is a throwback to
the 40s you know the way he talks the
way he acts it's all set in that
time period time period
well
i'm gonna tell you guys
a couple of things that
i mean i watch serial killer stuff a lot
of the time that they were
i
identifying where these
guys could have started
i had
four of the five
things happen to those guys that they
became serial killers
and i'm sitting there watching and i'm
like that
that's
oh all right i don't have any pictures
of me as a baby
and
i remember
my mom being with men and me
they're trying to like
keep me out of the room and and i knew
and i mean that's [ __ ] hard man for
any kid boy girl whatever
to i mean your childhood isn't gonna be
great
but you don't want it to be like like
that for anybody
for a girl her identification of a man
what she looks for in a man
for
you know somebody that's a kid that you
know that thing is you're looking for
something and somebody that is not
looking for it in you
that's
it's tough to grow up like that
so you know oh yeah a lot of these guys
like you interviewed a lot and they all
i mean they all don't become that but
they become
you know
that guy in the store that
you know is [ __ ] to be an [ __ ] 24
hours a day
are you hey man you really shouldn't
probably be a customer service if
you know you can't get out of your own
way i mean you never really thought
about
having an identity at work that was
different than your identity at home
and i think these guys they live in a
area that they create these false
personalities right
oh yeah definitely they live in a world
of you know fantasy
you know
you know i have a theory especially with
um what i'm thinking with the killers
interviewing them you know especially
with the ones that have trouble with the
mothers you know growing up um or the
mothers have abandoned them which i see
a lot of
and then you have the first rejection
which is normal for every kid to go
through whether you're male or female we
all have our first rejection we have our
first heartbreak very normal except when
you have a kid who now has probably you
know an underlying antisocial
personality coupled with now um an
abandonment of a mother and now he's
getting rejected from his first
heartbreak
you know where the perfect storm is kind
of brewing so i think a lot of times
when i see these killers they kind of
take captive of their victims you know
it doesn't even have to be either not in
a cabin of woods but maybe even for the
night like he was with richard ramirez
you know um just even in the mountains
with what whitaker norris said they're
taking these girls hostage captive but
they're making them playing to their own
fantasy and this is why i think what's
happened is from this upbringing from
their you know anti-social personality
is now they
have this false illusion this false
fantasy that they have to keep a woman
hostage to feel any type of you know
emotion or love that they're trying to
gain and even though it's a false sense
of love or you know emotion from them
you know this is a fan food that they're
playing into their minds where they're
trying to capture that they're trying to
capture this love or emotion that
they've lacked their entire lives
do they ever disconnect from that they
do they ever disconnect and can they
maybe be a little bit more down the
middle for like five years and then go
back to it or they're either you think
they're always a bit like that
you mean like do they like go through a
cooling off period or they try to like
get on the street yeah i mean there's a
ton of examples you look at you know the
green river killer which you mentioned
you know he got married and he was kind
of like off for um a couple years you
look at btk
you know knock mary for a couple years
you know a lot of them go through this
cooling off period um and maybe it's
because they're capturing something that
they've been searching for or maybe you
know
it could be for you know a lot of
different reasons you know cereal can go
through different uh stages as they kill
and they go through a very depression
period right after the killing you know
and then they work back up to chasing
the dragon almost like a drug addict
type of way where they you know need to
capture that back and you know nothing's
ever going to capture that fantasy
nothing you know any fantasy in real
life what any person has nothing is ever
going to match up to that fantasy that
they're chasing
and same with the singulars who are
going to believe that you know this is
um going to be a reality what they're
picturing in their mind but the killing
of the torture with the rape you know
wanting that um whatever they're
searching for some of them are searching
for like that sense of you know love
they've gotten you know rejected from
their mother from their first rejection
they're searching for it um they're
never gonna find that of course with a
victim that they're searching for like
in the perfect uh in in whittaker's like
perfect world what do you think he would
have wanted to be
if he had you know he talked to me about
you know his mother and the
ex-girlfriend so much and i actually
tracked down this high school girlfriend
you know 40
no almost 50 years later
no
60 years later
yeah so they did in high school and i
found him
um you know right after he died that was
a
i finally tracked her down and you know
when i talked to her i said you know he
talked about you until the day he died
and she was like we were just like high
school kids that were getting you know
soda and he would drive me up to these
mountains which i found out were san
gabriel mountains and she was just like
a flame like a high school boyfriend
nothing serious and i was like oh wow
because you know whittaker was talking
to her like this is my one true love my
first love and she's just like you know
just a high school thing
so it was really telling when i finally
got to talk to her and um she was um
really embarrassed you know she had
actually a stack of newspapers of
whitaker and the crime she had hidden
under her bed and she was so scared her
children were going to find them
throwing them out
but i remember just talking to her and
she was just like i i had no idea and i
was like listen he wasn't a serial
killer you know when you were dating him
of course but you know it's amazing
seeing how much guilt she held onto all
these years of her high school boyfriend
who went on to become a serial killer
from her rejection from him
damn those guys
what did she look like
blonde hair blue eyes and she wore it
across
like school but he wasn't an attractive
guy right i mean he
he was thin and you know he wasn't
he wasn't
unappealing right i mean
well according to hollywood he's
attractive which i didn't necessarily
know
hollywood has deemed vinegar norris
considerably attractive i think that's
why they've um
you know made it on to tv
but you know when i look at them when i
see the pictures of them next to each
other all i see is like these 70s uh
porn b rated porn stars when i see a
picture of them
see each other
it's funny how that how that
just the single mustache yo
you're one of a few guys i could pull it
off
where
that became like the porn stash you know
like a guy with a mustache
[ __ ]
you could be like a good looking dude
and girls will see you and they're gone
what do you think that guy the guy with
the porn stash and you're like man i got
a game over you know
i had to make money on the side
somewhere
yeah i think you know
but charm goes a long way i think in
fooling people if you want to be a good
salesman
right
what are the things what are the
commonalities that those guys have that
they're they're like they're
bullshitters i think they're master
manipulators
yeah that's they were good at mastermind
like masterful at what they do
it's easy to lie to people if you just
tell them something they want to hear
it really is
you know that and it sounds simple
doesn't it
yeah
they've all told me you know i look at a
human and i think what do they want
that's the first question they ask
themselves is what does that human want
and we can almost like they're better
than the fbi profilers they know how to
look at a person and be like this is
what that person is seeking you know so
they'll know if that person wants drugs
but that person wants money that person
is looking for love they pry on love and
attention and that's a basic human thing
that everybody kind of wants and they
pry on that like no other so you know
they know exactly what to say what to do
what you want to hear so i mean when
people are like oh i could never be a
victim i was like no everybody can be a
victim because these guys are looking at
a specific human being and they know
exactly what you want they're looking at
you and trying to figure out exactly
what you want to hear what you want and
they're trying to give it
you know to
lure you in as a victim
see in other words if some gorgeous sexy
young lady wanted me she'd just come up
and say hey you want another taco
that would be good
they would come up to me and say you
want to be left alone yes
how is you how old is your son now romeo
he's
he's three
i think i think he was kicking in there
because i think even he knew i gotta get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah
yeah my mom's talking to this dude i
gotta get the i'm i'm not even supposed
to be born here but i'm ready to get the
hell out of here he just had a recent
birthday didn't he
he did yeah it was his third birthday um
but yeah he actually was in the womb at
saint quinn so he actually talked to
lawrence bittiker
wayne adams ford and douglas clark he
talked to so this kid is actually gone
up against three serial killers before
he even was birthed
yeah well what did you think when you
went to uh san quentin uh uh what was
your
when you first started to go there
you know it was my first prison
experience you know you go through
college and you hear about prison and
the classes and kind of that kind of
stuff but you know nothing prepares you
for the field which deal will tell you
nothing could ever prepare you for the
field um but we get there and you know
it's it's petrifying you're going not
only into a prison you're going onto
death row which is a whole different
ball game and um i was petrified and you
know you're going through the steel
doors you're going through security
check and then you get inside and you
find out that it's not like you see on
the movies it's not a phone with the
glass where you're you know speaking of
the phone it's not like that you
actually go
into a cage a tiny little cage like a
dog's
kennel style cage
in with them and they are uncuffed
unchained and you're just in this cave
with them
yeah that's terrifying
i just can't imagine what it would be
like thinking uh i didn't like going to
san quentin
and i don't know if they're still doing
it back that they used to sign a waiver
no hostage clause they're not going to
negotiate for you
you know get down the ground or get your
back up against the wall because they're
going to start shooting they're not
going to negotiate for you
what it would be like
for a lady to go in there and and
especially make no if ands or butts
about a very attractive lady
so blond-haired blue-eyed with all the
accoutrements going in there with all
those men
that have very little to lose by acting
out
so that had to be
a frightening experience
did they have more than one guard with
you escorting you
no there's only you know probably the
same as you had you know one guard on
the outside one guard on the inside of
the cages and you know they're
patrolling but they're patrolling you
know i think it's 14 cages um in the u
shape i'm not sure exactly how you had
to go in with richard um but that's
pretty much what it is you know the two
guards on the inside outside and yeah
you have to sign the waiver because of
course you know if a riot breaks out you
know they're not coming for you you're
on your own i just want to clarify so i
never went up there to see richard not
not san quentin
i went to san francisco to see him in
court but i've never been up san quentin
to see richard i've gone there in other
cases so it wasn't
as scrutinized as death row is
so i didn't have to go through that
death row i've heard stories about
richard how crazy he was in the visiting
room
i've had i've heard stories as well by
guards that work there and other retired
cops that have
uh been up there yeah and the inmates
didn't like him he was
exposing himself to uh
other visitors there
and uh
him and this guy peterson
uh got into a pretty hectic uh
altercation
where
there was actually one was trying to
kill the other guy and a lot of stuff
went on
i didn't worry about it not my problem
anymore
deal with local stuff down here but he
was supposed to be nasty
i didn't care yeah i'm
the same yeah and can get pretty wild in
those visiting rooms um from what i've
heard
i've only had the alarm go off once when
i was there [ __ ]
and how what did you what did you think
of that
it's terrifying you hear the alarm going
off and it's stop all movement you know
something's going down so they stop
everything you can't move you can't do
anything you know the alarm's going off
something's going on first thing you
don't know what's going on first thing
you say is romeo hide don't say anything
[ __ ]
i mean and and
you know you you were you had an
interest in it it never it never
deterred you huh you'd never it never
made you not want to go
no it's always felt almost like a
mission like this is what i've meant to
do since i was a kid so it was um
just always felt like you know this is
what i was meant to do and for some
reason something kept bringing me back
to whitaker he was the most challenging
of the serial killers i had to deal with
and i'm like why am i harping on
one that's so challenging when i have a
ton of others i could be you know
interviewing for study
why am i keep going back to this
challenging one and something could
bring me back bring me back to him kept
trying and um
you know it was finally when he he gave
everything up i was it was almost like
an aha moment where i was like okay this
is why i was meant to keep going back to
this one and keep trying him like so
hard
yeah
i think that's you know the
that's the one perseverance uh-huh the
the the toughest
uh what are some of the who are some of
the other
guys you talk to or people that you talk
to
well during the time i was pregnant i
did wayne adam ford and douglas clark
douglas is the sunset slayer
in los angeles so he was killing girls
you know along the sunset he had a
partner as well but he had a female
partner
there was a lot of decapitation with
their case um wayne adam ford was a
truck driver a killer in california
um he actually was a rare one because he
actually turned himself into the police
uh and he turned himself in with a human
breast in his pocket in a ziploc bag oh
my god
did you hear about that no man
this first thought i'd hear about wow
when did that occur
it was in the 90s yeah it made national
news at the time
do you know what part of california that
occurred
it was northern northern let's see i
looked up the wikipedia page so he
turned himself in november 1998 in
humboldt county sheriff's department in
eureka california there's all that weed
up there there growing in humboldt
county i think that would have chilled
him out
well she yeah i mean
yikes what uh what a world what's
happening what's up you wanna cheat here
yeah right with those hanging around
i mean man that's
what yes so really something i don't
know man that's
i mean
especially because the inside of a
breast is all fat
i don't know why somebody want to hold
on to that stuff
yeah a lot of questions with this one
yeah what's that guy's name
that's uh wayne adam ford
maybe we can get him on a guest he
smiled
in his uh he's still alive yeah still
alive yeah
yeah
turn himself in
huh you are
yeah
um he you know his son was only young
when this was happening but um
reconnected i went out to visit him and
he's a really good kid um
and he has a lot of questions about his
father so you know i've kind of been
like that liaison between him and his
dad
happening
wow what does a dad feel about his his
family
you know he really wants to you know
connect with his son kind of you know
answer these questions for him i can't
even imagine what being the son of a
serial killer and the questions you
probably have you know of like
you know are
passed on am i you know gonna you know
embody these you know i can't even
imagine you know i was just watching i
don't know if you guys watched dexter i
was just watching the latest episode and
i was like you know dexter's son just
you know got some of the traits so i can
imagine you know anybody who has that as
a parent you know you probably have
those
questions that you know most of us don't
have
you know as a kid
wow i mean is there forgiveness or i
mean can he can you think his son can
live a normal life what would it would
consider normal but yeah he's living a
really good life you know he has a
girlfriend now he's in love with and
they have a kid together and he's doing
really well and
you know i've watched a lot of serial
killers kids and me doing well they're
doing you know working through you know
having that stigma attached to them most
of them kind of detach from it um but
they lead very normal lives
themselves
what do you what do you make of the
fascination of people with with serial
killers like from the inside
like we're looking at the inside you're
on the inside
uh yeah
personally i think a lot of people who
like true crime um i don't find it a lot
of people want to put into like a
group of like their groupies which i
don't believe at all i think the reason
we all like serial killers the reason
all of us now are talking today is
because of a criminal instinct you know
we are primal beings we are animals at
the end of the day and the thing is
somebody you know
first species which is a serial killer
they threaten our species because they
are actually killing off human beings
and that was against you know why we're
here to reproduce
so this is kind of why we are you know
inclined to learn about them is because
we want to know about our predators that
are you know threatening us you know you
look at week we have a huge thing in
shark week on discovery channel that
everybody turns in for it's because it's
you know a predator that is you know
could kill us so anytime there is a
predator that is you know coming for us
or that kind of thing always going to
you know um
give us an inclination to learn about
them and fascination and you know it's
almost like hyper vigilance we want to
learn about that predator as much as we
can so we can you know fight against it
then certainly social media has got to
be driving it
you know now you have the ability which
they didn't have there wasn't the
coverage in the toolbox killers
now you have social media
driving things and driving this true
crime and
people that are involved in it and they
love telling stories with each other and
sharing their thoughts
yeah yeah it's a
social norm
you know true
but also i think that people
um can set themselves up more to be
victims by of somebody that's
manipulating them through
dms i mean
you know there was a guy that was
pretending to be a record producer or
pretend to be a woman and guys were
sending them mon i mean you know it's
it's manipulation i think in that oh
yeah
that people can be easily manipulated or
or want to be
in a relationship so bad
that they go against their instincts i
think is
anybody
anybody looking or starving for
attention
uh we did a videotape on an old gangster
uh his name was stomper he used to be
from grape street watts
and he says gang members associate with
each other because it's like forming
their own family it's their own group
they protect each other they love each
other they give what they couldn't get
from their own families
so now they're together so now you have
a group of people that are into true
crime and now you have the social
ability
to exchange that where
people would normally sit there's how
you're crazy you're following this [ __ ]
now you've got a group of people that
are into it we don't need those
outsiders we got us that's working hard
yeah oh yeah
gangs cults same thing you know you
they're getting that same sense
is a cult leader um
do are they are they manipulated or do
they really believe in what they're
saying i believe they're mastered
reverend jim jones yeah you know got
everybody to drink the punch
you know and he got everybody to move
out out of there and i have
a friend whose wife actually left him
to go over wow oh wow and uh
manipulator you know they're promising
something that nobody else will do for
them
there you go that's that's well said
they're promising something that
somebody won't do for them
yeah
i was so
crazy story i actually joined a cult
um not to join a cult joy nicole but i
was a death row inmate out of san
quentin uh paid three thousand dollars
for me to go into what's called a
leadership university
but it was cult um
and i did it basically for research so i
actually went through the course and it
was a hundred day course and it was very
coldish
um and it just happened to be from
someone in san quentin's death bro that
actually paid for me to go through it
and i learned a lot from it and i would
definitely say it's probably
it's very manipulative it's more for you
know greed for money um from the
organization um and then i think there
are leaders that uh
it's definitely all master manipulators
but i think there are some that actually
believe that they are
you know this you know prophet or
messiah you know come down to earth and
it but it's all feeding their ego at the
same time
why did jim jones want to go to guyana
i have no idea because he could so he
could
create a kind of like a
village there that they would grow their
own food that i guess they wouldn't be
interfered with by authorities or
i think that yeah isolation isolation
from all the people in their families in
a foreign country
you know
they looked it up on what they did
uh they went to so they said on guyana
as a favorite location citing its recent
revolution and socialist governments as
well as the favorable reaction jones had
received when he traveled there in 1963.
that was an eye-opening time for
america or the world to see
what a cult leader could do by
manipulating people i mean remember that
the senator or congressman got um shot
yeah they were trying to get away from
there
uh the cameraman that was with him that
took the footage of them actually
getting shot
he had been with us uh just a little
time before that he rode around with my
partner myself for two weeks with
geraldo rivera doing a thing for
nightline and he was in my car and
he left us
and
then he went to guyana and
last footage was him getting killed man
unbelievable
it's unbelievable
and you know they they i mean you know
people stay you know if you're of a
certain amount of means you know then
you'd stay like in a you know dumpy
hotel or a motel and you know you're
gonna be around those people maybe your
circumstances are you're not you know
you don't have a lot of money but you're
in a more dangerous situation
oh yeah
you know for the one that i was in we
had to raise five thousand dollars for
charity which is a ton of money we had a
week's time to raise it and then we also
had to enroll five people into it and
that's three thousand dollars a person
and
so you know you're paying also for the
travel cost um the class cost so i mean
you're talking crazy amount of money in
a very short period of time
that you're handing over
how did you do that
i was lucky because
you know i was you know the class is
paid for
um i was able to skate by with the
raising of the money um
just by family and friends just helping
me out and then when it came time where
i had to enroll the five family members
of friends i had called to death row in
may and i said you got me into this
you're getting me out of this
so it was him to you know get the
recruits
and that's how i kind of
but the rest of the people had to enroll
by people for three thousand dollars a
pop and i had just pretty much just said
to the death row and mate you're you've
got me into this you're getting me out
of this you're you it's on you to do my
recruits pretty much
wow wow
that's crazy you said him it's on you to
do my
it's on youtube
she's got a lot of intestinal fortitude
now young age
yeah you really do
you don't [ __ ] around either that's
pretty good
well he got me into the situation he's
getting me out of this situation
i would i don't think a lot of people
would do that
i think you know
you know um
it's not trying to miss the right way
that
it's it might it may be more productive
to
be a female to understand
do you know what i'm saying to
understand that
the mind of somebody like that than a
male that is a gender related that i
don't know that is gender related just
the that the thing that we've talked
about before
they have an infinite amount of
understanding as to why they're doing
what they're doing and that's not gender
related you just have to have
understanding to know why they're doing
it
don't condone it yeah i understand it
it's gender related i think though
the men are more inclined to
you know open up to email they look at
you know this goes back to the mother
issue too i think they're more likely to
open up to a female just because they
feel safer they feel like women are more
empathetic
um than a moon
um but i think you know males have
strong points with getting them to open
up too i think it's you know a twofold
type of deal as well
yeah
so when somebody when somebody uh were
any of those guys closed off like really
closed off or were they communic where
they were they're communicating with you
you know somebody doesn't want to talk
or they say i don't want to talk about
that or
whittaker was closed off vinegar was
like the worst of the worst for three
years i mean he he would just you know
anything i tried i went to visit
even sending him the others he would
write back and he'd be like do you
understand english um because i was kept
writing and he was saying stop writing
so he'd be like do you understand
english little girl like kind of you
know very degrading
uh towards
because you know i was so persistent i
just would not stop writing him um but i
just kept trying and yeah but he was the
one who stolen called me he just did not
want to talk to me and finally it was
just like a damn breaking when i finally
got to him
what was it that broke me thinking yeah
i was just wondering that
i think you know
i kind of tricked him because you know i
had i when i became pregnant and i only
had you know fifteen hundred dollars my
bank account and i had been kicked by my
ex and he had said you know you're on
your own so i and i just lost a job the
company i was working went into
bankruptcy
so i said i'm about to be a mom you know
i'm i'm six months pregnant at this
point and i said you know i'm gonna go
to san quentin and spend this money and
do this round of interviews and finish
you know this study that i've been
working on for five years i'm gonna
finish it at least you know i'm gonna
work towards something finish something
with my son
so i had contacted wayne adam ford and
douglas clark and i said i'm coming and
i'm gonna finish the study and i'm gonna
interview you guys and i want to do a
book on it and we're like okay and i
said i want you to tell lawrence
whitaker that i'm coming and then i'm
pregnant and if he wants me to visit
with him that he has to call me himself
and it was kind of like a shot in the
dark i didn't think he would actually do
it and then
sudden i get the call from
san quentin and i pick it up and i hear
you know you have a call from lawrence
whitaker
and i just remember
stunned that like this is the first time
after three years and i had already
visited with him he's calling me
and he's like i hear you're pregnant and
you're coming out and i was like i am
and i just kept him on the phone kept
him questions after questions
you know um
trying to build a rapport on the phone i
wanted to be comfortable to call me
whatever he wanted to and just talk and
it wouldn't be like an awkward silence
or anything like so i just kept talking
and talking and asking questions
and then
you know now he's calling me a couple a
week and now he's calling me daily and
it's you know it's stuck like that until
the day he died calling me like pretty
much daily
and when i went out to visit him and
that's when he gave me all the
information was he calling you collect
no he was calling me through gtl
which is like a prison phone system
do they
are they were those calls like the the
did the prison pay for it or did he have
a family to put money in an account or
no i paid for all the calls oh oh okay
oh okay yeah yeah
that's the reason i have um
a san francisco number is so we get a
very cheap calls
right
yeah
people always like do you live in san
francisco i'm like no it's just for the
inmates to call me so it's wicked cheap
you know uh for the murders a former
member of the behavioral science unit
fbi he was a profiler
and we had a lot in common
when i was doing this nightstalker case
and people weren't believing i was a
young investigator so i didn't have the
experience that the others did
uh a dear friend of mine bill agemeier
uh called me up that's the guy that
called me up the day we were on the golf
course
and bill hagmeyer said
uh he told me years ago he said when
these guys he says they'll stonewall you
they won't talk to you they won't do
[ __ ] and then they'll start they'll
[ __ ] you they won't tell you the
truth
and all of a sudden
they'll finally just realize you know
hey
there's nothing more there than to tell
you the truth they'll open up with one
thing and once they open up with the
first time
then the floodgates open up
and they'll talk to you about anything
you want to know
wow so that's essentially what it sounds
like
as you're talking he's the first person
i thought of you know he yeah when he
finally thought okay
she's not going to chase me anymore this
is it ah
now
i'll let her in a little bit i'll give
her that phone call because i don't want
to lose the maybe one of the few
contacts he had from the outside that
had
shown allegiance to him because she'd
been trying for three years
now i'll reach out and i'll
stay with me
and then he found you to be a friend and
he opened up
exactly
that's you know i uh
i got a a
call from this guy that uh
wrote a book on charles manson jeff
somebody one of the last books
of uh
that you know he was already
you know almost toward the end of his
life and
the
the reporter said to him you know how do
you how do you spend your
time now you know what are you what are
you doing and he goes well you know i
listen to classic rock you know he loves
rock he goes i'm a friend uh i'm a fan
of john wayne
frank sinatra
and george lopez
there you go
and the guy said send it to my manager
and he goes uh
let george know
that you know i'm working on this book
on charles manson and
that's
charles manson this is his quote
and i was like
charles manson
and then somebody said go see him and i
said man are you crazy
like my career would be over so you know
uh i think
for me like cancel culture
i think if i had gone to i wouldn't go
but um
if i had gone
can you you can imagine you know and and
also years ago when
fox was doing uh different kind of
specials on comedy
they asked me to go
to
[Music]
was a it might have been sanguine to go
do a special in prison and i said no
because i i didn't think that people
were in there who were in there
deserve to be entertained
you know i said i couldn't do it and
paul rodriguez did it
which i don't really i guess he's in his
own prison let me officially say thank
you
i i and it didn't and nobody could
believe that because it was
a big it became a big special and i
couldn't do it
i couldn't go and i told and they were
thought i was crazy like you're turning
it down i i can't go i don't know why i
don't know where that came from because
i didn't have any a father or mother but
i just thought that
you know if you're in there
i didn't uh
richard told me that
he would get in touch with me and he
wanted to talk to me again he says
probably take about seven years of him
being because he won't talk to me about
four more murders here in l.a county
and
phil carlo the guy that wrote the book
he called me and he said hey gil
rich
wants to talk to you
my first reaction was i said deliver
this message back to rich
if he's gonna tell me the truth
and not [ __ ] me
i'd love to go see him but if he's gonna
take me down a [ __ ] road well then
no
and my thought being because if i went
up there to see him
that's like a trip to disneyland for him
yeah he's in there he's not in there for
rehabilitation and i'm not there to
entertain him
you got something to say this is work
it's official i'm not your good buddy
this was a relationship that we had
so i didn't go see him
uh then
and as it turned out
then i reached out to him years later
one of my guys had to go up saint quinn
i said hey ask rich
he wants to see me
and they said he was all excited hey got
some guys here from l.a want to see you
and he came up to the door wow
they said hi rich they said hello he's
very friendly and they said hey
uh you remember gil carrillo
wants to know if you want him to come up
and see it he said no turn away walked
away from the door
so that's slammed so
so much you know and
that's when bill hagmeyer told me no you
gotta go you gotta go let them [ __ ]
do anything yeah
uh just to keep the doors open yeah i'm
talking you
how old yeah you wanna get them to yeah
you do it
yeah i think if you get them talking
they won't stop talking sure
yeah i believe that yeah
and then they don't i mean they might
want to even maybe
edit themselves but then they can't help
it
yeah well you know
there's no
there's no microphone in the cage so
they kind of like they have a free reign
so you can kind of go in there and be
like talk and they'll start talking
and you kind of let them hang themselves
with their own tongue once you get in
there
um but it is a tight rope because you're
kind of like the same way gill is
talking it's kind of the same way i go
in it's like i'm not going to move this
trip for nothing
you know i'm not walking out there
empty-handed
um
so you've got to kind of make that
stools with them i'm not walking out of
here empty-handed and this isn't play
time you know um
we can i'm going to still come see you
but you kind of got to put your foot
down before you even go in
and to let them know you mean business
while we're there
and and he by this time he really didn't
need me he had a fan club there was
people following me got married and you
know that's why he didn't want to talk
to me because i had spoken out against
marriage
and
so
but they do have i mean
they have fans and they have devotees
and all that stuff right
oh yeah uh whittaker had a girlfriend
the entire time i was interviewing him
geez
yeah did you talk to her
um after he died i did
reached out to her
and what did she have to do yeah
well she didn't really have much to say
you know she didn't see him too much uh
she was over in ireland um but he had a
wife too right after he was arrested in
79 he actually got married for a little
bit and then they got divorced um
and yeah so i mean these guys do they
get married they have girlfriends they
have outside relationships and it's
almost something you have to work
against while you're
you know interviewing them it almost
work against everything you want to do
like gil said you know he had a fan club
and everything you know he didn't want
to talk to me at that point but you know
especially they have i would say like
with ramirez
uh and no you know you they have that
kind of this unbroken bond of the
investigator and first serial killer
same with like vinegar one you know i i
was investigating going through his
trial transcripts you know uh police
discovery there's this it's a different
bond you have with them because you're
you know going deep deep into their case
and you know them better than anybody in
their case better than everybody so it
actually worked for you in many ways
too yeah [ __ ]
how far are you i'm sure remembrance
thought about you until the day he died
go
[Laughter]
i hope in a friendly way
yeah well i i still
uh he i know he didn't
hate me that bad i had helped him out
with his family
and his family was going through a rough
time after his conviction
so i had friends from el paso go and
start making passes contact family tell
me
take care of them they had nothing to do
with what he was going through
and since then i've run into other
family members of his
a matter of fact one that had been
sexually molested for six years
by him
and she was his niece he was
he was her uncle
so i still keep in touch with the family
i have no no problems there
uh
richard's sister
this young lady
her dad was richard's brother
richard had a sister
and
that sister just recently because i just
heard from the gal
uh was really pissed off because she had
done a television
uh
tamara hall she did the tamara hall show
to expose the fact
that when kids tell you that they've
been sexually molested listen to them
and give them the attention do not deny
them
and that's what had happened to her in
her life
well now the sister came at her
and was condemning her how could she go
on television say that richard had done
this
there was no need to bring it up there
was no need to do this nobody
and she's convinced that they gave her
oodles of money they didn't give her a
nickel
but she thought she was just trying to
make money off her brother and this is
after he's already dead
it's it was senseless
and i've even told her necessarily i'll
go back talk to family
set them straight
i mean
it uh going through the going through
the years of these guys and even you
know seeing
uh like btk or son of sam that they're
enamored with each other like if
one guy's a fan of the other they all
know of each other and you know they're
enamored of
like us they're saying oh that guy knows
me you know like it's they're it's their
own club uh bundy and richard
communicated together they wrote back
and forth to each other
if ana had any intestinal fortitude at
all when they
executed bundy
i wanted to send richard to telegram
saying see you in hell and sign it from
ted oh my god i was afraid i'd get in
trouble so i didn't
yeah but but they did and richard was
intelligent enough to just say he's got
an ego that'll fill this room wow and
studied serial killers could tell you
anything from the time the romans fed
the christians to the lions modern day
serial killers so they did have their
own group
also he said that yeah once he got found
out that they're they're kind of they
deflate because their ego's so big that
oh yeah their egos are
astronomical compared to you know normal
people it's they have this ego that
wants to be filled
and you know with what you said gill
about um the sister um
one thing i've found is you know going
through the cases of especially
bitterness there's so many unknown
victims that we're not killed but you
know if you watch the documentary you
see tracy who is the neighbor
of whittaker and how much drama she's
still dealing with so you see a lot of
the victims that weren't necessarily
killed but still victimized by these
guys
you know i enjoyed it uh of the
documentary i think now talking to you i
i think you know to go back and watch it
now uh
is it
it's more interesting now
listening to you and then watching now
if i go back and watch it a little bit
of the back story of of it
same thing i watched it after i met with
you
but after this after talking today
i want to go back and watch it again
it's on peacock is that right it's the
toolbox killers on
streaming on peacock right so for our
audience to check it out please go and i
think if there was a nancy drew
and if she was an old lady and they saw
her and go hey nancy drew
this young lady right here you inspired
her to be
this person
i think nancy drew would
she'd be proud she would be very proud
of you you'd be proud
guys that means a lot to me
i hope so
you know you know that's my one i think
absolutely i mean
those are stories you know that you hear
that i mean people tell stories every
night to their kids and they read to
their kids
or sometimes they don't like
um
my when i was married
my wife
read to mayan
um
[Music]
i think my american express no it wasn't
[Laughter]
the
and i think it does it does stem it does
start
creativity because it's not music
it's the actual written word and it's
coming from a
human voice not a book on tape or or
things and i think those things are
influential to
to children at that you know like it got
into you and like
if
if it hadn't happened would you have
found your way to that but it gave you
something that you could hold on to
you know learn from and then be an
expert at which is amazing
yeah it's really you know awesome you
know to have a role model even if it's
fictional to look up to where
you know that's
inspired to be like you know and she's a
great role model and i hope there's you
know other role models out there that
kids can look up to you know i'm going
to be reading romeo uh the hardy boy
probably in a couple years
hopefully
yeah that's awesome
what a great how great is that what a
great circle that is to like be able to
read him the hearty boys and
yeah
well my dad when i my dad was the one
read me nancy drew and he always you
know i created a monster i never thought
you were going to take nancy drew and go
this far and
i'd be driving you to san quentin one
day he was the first person who actually
took the same point oh wow
so yeah he had to think it was it had to
be a trip
to go back and remember his little girl
and then going and seeing that right
yeah yeah it was a trip for him
which is a great movie i think you know
that there's a movie in your story in
there that's a great
you know oh yeah it all comes from a
circle and you have a long
you know you have a long future ahead of
you she does amazing
and the door has been
open for her she's got a foot in that
door now
because of your work i do i'm hopeless
and lucky and i said to gil i'm hoping
he you know helps me out with the
searches we're trying to get going for
the girls and everything
and
you know gil has been just amazing just
the time we've met together what you've
taught me and
you know um you've been a role model for
me well well thank you and i look
forward to working with you uh by the
way where did we meet for dinner that
one night do you remember the name of
the place oh
i'm gonna let george say it
there's better places
how dare you that's my cheers brother
it totally is he does his best work in
there
yeah
i mean it was incredible going to that
booth seeing that back booth you had gil
with the phone where you'd be getting
those calls about the night stalker like
for me it was iconic just to sit there
in that booth
it was a family business the only place
back at the time before we had wow cell
phones they had a phone jack
we'd go work right there that would be
that's
my sub office
i've just learned an important fact here
i'm trying to get gil to let me in the
uh um
the other jail uh lincoln heights jail
that that old retire that old retired
one yeah that's lapd's
that's that that's lapd's job i'm a
little bit of a of a uh
ghost hunter well that i don't i don't
hunt them they're in my house they're
already there
uh
but those things fascinate me like i i
was fascinated growing up by
abandoned
buildings
um and things like that that were or
houses
because i would go in there and think
that people
once lived in here you know when you go
to school you're walking to school and
there's an abandoned house every kid
goes to the abandoned house and walks
through there charlotte homes and uh i
would always think of like who lived
here what was the story behind it
so then
um
my daughter says to me you know you ever
check out youtube they got a lot of that
stuff on there and then from that i
don't watch any other tv other than
youtube or abandon
buildings or
there's one that those guys go into
those buildings and there's this door
that's there and the guy
uh the door falls and there's a guy back
there with a knife and like a mask on
that and that
you know there's a scream and then
there's a scream when a man is here
because the door dropped that the guy's
like this with a knife and that dude is
like ah he's like
they run camera right i mean it's
i'm gonna tell you right now this
mexican knows why those places were
abandoned in the first place ain't no
need to go back inside
[Laughter]
and so we know it's funny because i
actually do urban exploring and
paranormal investigation just as fun
it's like my i just like to investigate
for fun but i do the urban exploring
which is the abandoned buildings
and they go something too
they say all the good ones are taken
you know i i know
i know a uh good friend of yours
uh momo
he does that stuff he's done that he
does that too he goes out with him and
his friend hefty don't hefty and
uh they talk about stuff like that and i
say hey have a nice trip i'm not home
momo come and tell her the story of uh
of being at that park oh momo's here
what are the odds here mama come grab a
mic no he is this is uh yeah grab a uh
you can hop in right here that's where
you can hear yourself and everything
uh explain to her uh a little bit of
that alice momo
uh laura we did this park in uh in the
city of uh downey and around pico too
and we have this um
there's been words of things happen that
part a lot of um
just floating a lot of orbs and pictures
more unusual than usual so we went to do
the investigation about three am
and i had a medium with me he was named
aj barrera amazing medium and he was
already tracking some kind of energy
by the playground
and as we're talking about this
he says we need to leave right now
there's two guys arguing behind me
and we took a picture and we know we we
had some great equipment
there's two gangster looking dudes
behind him the silhouettes
and
you know we see it right away we kind of
run out of the
the area we we kind of calm down we we
kind of you know try to regroup and then
we do an evp session that's electric
voice phenomenon when you record
you know uh ghost voices and you play
them back in higher frequency and during
that evp session we actually caught a
little girl saying i jump
and it's so clear that the i jump voice
um we later find out that you know
there's a you know a few suicides there
and there's been a few murders there
of little girls
oh my god [ __ ] i mean and then speaking
about the abandoned buildings we did the
alexandria hotel
the one in downtown the layoff of off of
spring and we did this
we did the seventh floor and we couldn't
find anything in there but we didn't we
did a
little search about what was going on
there nothing and then one day we're
packing up and aj and i both see
this young little girl walk out of the
elevator
and i think that's when i stopped doing
the ghost hunts for a while because he
kind of freaked me out a little bit
and after like a month of research we
found out that in 1909 the architect's
daughter fell through the elevator shaft
i mean it was just
crazy and uh i think gil was in our
podcast and
you know he had his own experiences on
our podcast this is this is the closest
i've ever been to momo since then i
don't i those things
it's funny how people have that uh you
know that their intuit intuitive or
you know momo i i you know
like i've been faster that you are i
have
so my grandfather used to call me uh
encanto which means like enchanted but i
took it as an insult because everything
was an insult so why would i not take
that as an insult and i didn't like it
you know i didn't like when he called me
that
and um
momo was in my
room upstairs and we were talking and he
said
he said what did you say what i just you
know i got a vision of a song that i
remember from back in the old days my
mom used to sing and part of it is he
says encanto
and and i even say man is the wording
conforming anything to you
and it was out of the blue it was random
but then i think we were just
on a we were reviving george and i were
vibing that day we had a good creative
session and i think when you vibe with
someone you can kind of like being
intuitive anything trying to get at them
or or around them and i think that's
what happened
that day but then i said to him
shot why did you say that
what made you say that and he's like i
don't how did you why did you say that
what made you say that
and he goes i just it came into my and
only my grandfather and my grandmother
would know that you know
and that's
that's
and then aj we have to have you oh man
we have to have you talk to aj
so so aj i meet through momo
and i was cleaning when the pandemic
kind of started i said oh just you know
i'll clean that and i found the bowl of
a watch that my grandfather used to wear
uh my whole childhood and he used to
wear the face
right here on the on the underside
so that part of that [ __ ] so when i
said can i go play
he would look down at his wrist and
instead of going like this he would look
down
and say no
by looking at the
you know he wouldn't even give me the
the decency to do that
he put it on the underside so he could
go no he'd look at the time
and go no
and i would be like man
so that day
i found the watch in my house
and then we talked to mom to aj momo and
i and aj said
your grandfather was like was he i don't
want to say he was dumb but was he like
simple i said yeah
and he worked like was he
con construction i said yes
he worked in construction and then
there's a little bit of pause and he
goes
he wants me to ask you what you found
today and i'm like that's holy [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i said i found this watch give me
another beer
i mean let me actually george i have a
medium i should hook you up with she is
unbelievable i mean the stuff she has
given to me she's worked cases with me
and i think she would blow you away with
some of this stuff too
now where did you get now how did that
start for you like how did that
what did they read la llorona books to
your dad
i know the whole urban legend i want to
say when you said the alexandria i was
like oh my god that's on my bucket list
because that was actually one of the
places whittaker lived he actually went
there in 79 before he moved to the scots
motel in burbank
uh with alexandria so it's been like my
dream to actually go along with their
investigation it's a lot of negative
things in that whole even the on the
seventh floor itself i think uh valentin
an actor a lot of suicides a lot of old
hollywood there um there's a lot of
things roaming around we have footage of
of a black uh like just
smoke flying around in one of the
kitchens and aj and i actually
discovered an underground um
room that was a prohibition hole from
one hotel to another
and oh my god agent i mean
aj discovered it just by hey man
something's telling me we need to go
lower
and we just kept on going lower until
till we found this
hole in the bottom of an underground
swimming pool that led us through
another hotel
i mean it's
that place has a lot everybody who's
worked there
or or even been there or even a tenant
there has said that place
is very unsettling especially around
because it's the only hotel that has
suicide doors still
wow what does that mean the doors that
you just opened up and they have nothing
oh [ __ ] you know like oh that's right
okay i tell you what if there's a line
to get in you can come i'll give you
butts you're gonna come right in front
of me i ain't going to please um
yes uh
i was in the chicago theater
and the meeting we used to meet people
is underground
and i was talking to two people
and something touched my arm and i
turned around
because i thought somebody was trying to
get my attention i thought there would
be somebody there and there wasn't
anybody there
and then whenever it happens to me
i just say it i said something touched
my arm
right now right behind me
right on the side of me something
touched my arm and the guy from the
chicago theater was across from me he
went
they have yes things in the hotel in
there and then um
at a theater in reading pennsylvania
we i would always go to the old theaters
and say
to as i was leaving is this place
haunted
and the guy says [ __ ] he goes his uh
so-and-so here and he goes no he left he
goes okay so get this he goes this guy
had gone away
came back and there was a woman that had
had passed an elderly woman who was a
an usher in a theater
and she had passed away but the guy
didn't know
and then he went backstage and the guy
said where were you and he goes i was
talking to lydia
uh for like the last 25 minutes and the
guy's like who
lydia
and he's like hey man
lydia died like six months ago and that
guy was like the [ __ ] yeah he goes i
just talked to her he goes man listen
man
she cast
he goes i was just at the in her aisle
at the top they were looking at each
other and she said she was standing like
she always did and she was filling me in
like what's been going on i said she
didn't tell you she died he goes no
we're just talking about she tells you
crazy i mean that kind of stuff is like
i've never seen an actual i've seen
well i've seen orbs in my house but not
an actual
physical i don't know what i would do if
i saw that it looks so real i mean i saw
one but it didn't look like in the
movies where they're see-through
you know it just looks like an it's our
level our on our ground
and that's what you call either a
residual haunting or you call it a uh
you know a grounded apparition
we're going to get you into the end
alexander you're called up in the rada
if you stay there brother we're gonna
all go to the alexandria hotel
i am so game for that if you guys will
do it
he's not gonna do it i'll do it but i
will i'll be your driver i would love to
meet your medium because i i i love that
yeah i will hook you up with her she's
she's pretty incredible
i've always wanted to actually go up to
the fire roads too and do a evp session
or something up there on the roads yeah
too um gil saw my video i went up there
in the middle of the night with a
machete because i had to get like some
video footage of a standpoint that
bittaker told me he goes you can see a
360 view of all the cars coming down
this road
where he took the victim so i went up
there in the middle of the night and i
took the video and i showed it to gil
and gil thought i was crazy that i was
gonna get killed up there i i thought
she was great it scared me looking at it
not not because i expected something to
jump out of her but it was dark
lighting was very poor
and i just the the angle she was
shooting at man she's gonna slip she's
gonna fall yeah you know i'm gonna be
the last person to see her alive
you know his video is it was it was
nerve-wracking send that video and see
if we could play it in a higher
frequency see if we pick up any vvps off
of it
oh it's a great idea actually yeah
that'd be cool i don't usually yeah if
you guys resembled
resend it to me and i'll get it to i'll
get it to normal yeah yeah
i will well thank you for being you know
i don't use this term a lot you are a
modern day marvel
oh
oh my god that means a lot coming from
you i'm such a huge fan my family's such
a huge fan too
thank you thank you but i'm not a modern
marvel you are i i
save those
compliments for very few people
and nobody at steven's steakhouse
but thank you for being on and it's been
incredibly interesting and now we have
things to do together
yes definitely
alexandria and we'll go to the jail in
the same day
that jail's supposed to be on it
i'm packing that day i'm telling you
right now i'm packing
i didn't even know it was there and you
can imagine what i thought when i saw it
i was like oh
because it has the bars on top on the on
top so that guys can't escape yeah thank
you get some great photos there guys
our relationships are just starting this
is just the end of the podcast we got
work to do together
that'd be fun yes
thank you laura seriously i'm done for
it thank you guys thank you guys so much
for having me on yes we loved it thank
you stay in touch
definitely bye guys beautiful bye thank
you that was awesome
you